hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
mystery and thriller movie called the
nest
there is a harmonious family who is
looking for items at the flea shop the
girl meg is suddenly attracted to a
teddy bear she then asks her mother beth
to buy her the teddy bear when she asks
the flea about the teddy bears price the
man says that the doll is given to the
girl for free even though beth tries to
pay the man still doesn't want her money
they finally come home from that place
after getting the things they want
unbeknownst to them in a house nearby
there is a girl watching them through
the window she strangely walks to her
family which turns out to be a nest of
parasitic insects back to the family
they are in the playground
from their conversation it turns out
that jack is beth's newest husband who
was a widow they also talk about their
new life in which they will settle in a
house on the outskirts of the city while
they are chatting their child
unwittingly is engrossed in playing with
her new teddy bear until she goes to the
forest to chat with the teddy bear but
unexpectedly there is something moving
inside the teddy bear until a few
moments later her parents realize that
their daughter has disappeared they
immediately look for her and suddenly
hear her screams from the forest
not knowing what happened earlier they
find meg unconscious and beside her
there is blood on her new teddy bear
six weeks later it seems meg is texting
her mother who is dating with her new
father
she continuously texts her mother
on the other hand they eventually feel
annoyed because lately meg really looks
different and doesn't want to be left
alone by her mother she always complains
of stomach ache as an excuse
because of that they finally go home
it turns out that meg is not alone in
the house
her mother leaves her to a friend named
marissa although she tries to get closer
to meg but always in vain
later marissa told her parents about
meg's strange behavior such as the
stomach ache she always has
even her parents are worried if she
keeps getting sick like that after her
work is done versa returns to her house
that night beth seems to have trouble
sleeping because she is constantly
thinking about meg
shortly after meg comes into beth's room
and she is acting weird
as a result her mother accompanies her
to sleep until morning
the next morning meg returns to school
after her previous accident however she
as usual doesn't want to be left by her
mother and constantly complains of
stomach pains then the psychologist at
the school ash tries to understand what
depression she has but she always
refuses when beth wants to go back to
her office meg still insists that she
doesn't want to be left at school
as a result she sadly sits in the school
corridor not long after a girl comes to
bully her meg fights back and something
strange happens something that looks
like an insect tail comes out of her
mouth
luckily the teacher is able to separate
them and meg apologizes as she seems to
be being controlled by something strange
at dinner meg wants to sleep with her
mother but jack reasons that she should
be independent by sleeping alone in her
room then the two start a fight but beth
finally calms them down by obeying her
daughter's wishes she reads a storybook
until meg falls asleep
and i know jack decides to work in the
warehouse
meanwhile it turns out that meg is not
asleep yet she comes to the warehouse
and does something terrifying the
parasitic insects come out of the teddy
bear and attack jack immediately
the next day beth is accompanying meg
who is having breakfast with excess
sugar while she still doesn't realize
where jack is
suddenly she happily accepts the call
because she has been accepted for a job
but meg seems doesn't like it because
she doesn't want to be left alone
later beth finds a smelly black liquid
on the warehouse floor while meg returns
to the school but she feels unhappy the
psychologist again asks her what has
been making her behavior so strange
lately she only says that her mother
will leave her alone but her mother is
supposed to stay with her waiting for
everything to be ready
obviously ash doesn't understand what
she means
he suddenly hears an insect-like sound
coming out of meg's body she
unconsciously hurt ash's hand but then
she apologizes after realizing her
actions just now
soon beth is surprised that meg doesn't
look so fussy in meg's room she finds
all the dolls are cut in the stomach
when she wants to tell jack about it the
teddy bear is suddenly on the stairs
causing her to slip and fall unconscious
in her semi-conscious state jack and meg
are having a conversation about his
mother's readiness
even when she is conscious she is again
given sleeping pills until she passes
out again
it turned out that they had been
controlled by something strange
after that jack calls ash and tells him
that meg won't be going back to school
next to jack it turns out that marissa
is already affected by the creatures
jack then comes to meg's school to meet
ash with a teddy bear an argument ensues
when ash tells him that meg has gone mad
and has injured his hand without further
ado jack starts his action using the
teddy bear as the result ash has also
been controlled by the creatures
in the meantime the time to fertilize
beth has come
with the teddy bear beside her finally
the parasitic creature comes out from
inside and wants to enter beth's body
fortunately she manages to get up first
and checks the condition of the house
she then sees jack and marissa who each
have the creature in their mouths
she asks them both to get away from the
house leaving herself meg and the teddy
bear behind
meg realizes that her followers are
waiting for the right time outside
beth wakes up in the middle of the night
and sees that meg is going into the
basement with her dolls
she decides to follow her and discovers
that meg has made a nest out of her doll
she eventually is hit by jack from
behind
after the incident beth continues to be
given drugs until half sane with the
opportunity meg tries to fertilize her
mother she takes her mother to the
toilet and starts the fertilization
process making her the main host
long story short the family members with
ash are busy cutting the doll's belly
meg is told by jack to feed her mother
with sugar
disturbingly beth has been made the
queen of insects from that time
the doll is used as a vessel for the
creature eggs that beth has produced
in that way the creatures continue to
reproduce
after the dolls are shown they
distribute the dolls to the flea shop
similar to the scene at the beginning of
the movie
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching
[Music]